運ちゃん肇社長ですちょっと昨日と今日と動画サボっちゃったんですけどその今日から
学校なんですよ
東京春休みの最後だったんでボーリング行ってきたんですよ
まぁ今まではこう
なんていうんだろうが一応学校授業単位は全部取りましたよ
全部とったんですけど毎日動画投稿してても全然
学校の勉強はできたんですけど大学3年生になるということで
学校の勉強以外のず分の
したいことも知っていかなくてはいけないなと思いまして動画の
投稿頻度がちょっと遅くなると思います
はい悟空 youtube 趣味で youtube 続けていきたいと思っているし
楽しいんですけど楽しんし続けていきたいんで
自分が干せそういう仕事に就いたあとっても続けていきたいと思っているんで
ここがちょっとこの大学3年生が
僕のそうライド結構
重要な時期になると思ってるんでこの勉強なんて良いですよ
もうアンチ動画投稿せても単位全部取れるぐらいだったんで自分が本当にしたいことは
あ
うちのマンチ投稿しているぐらいの
か時間の使い方ではたぶんできない気がするんで
学校の勉強+自分の痴態殺すよ
なかなかちょっとランチ動画だすのはキツイんで
ダウン動画の統合頻度は下がると思うんですけど
また
宜しくお願いします本当にねああ
将来的に
もっと価値のある動画とか
取れるような人間を目指しますね
しばらくの辛抱だと思います
出せるときはだしますけど
ちょっと出ないなと思っても
q してそんな死んだりしてないんで
大丈夫です
それですねちょっと皆さんに相談なんですけど僕今まではじめしたぞっていうのがやっ
てきたじゃないですか
ねっ
でもよく考えてください僕このまま3年生
向社会へ出ると
何かしら職に就くと思うんですけど
もしそんな新入社員というか下っ端の社員がですよ
ん
社長ってに乗ってたら
がすごい
怖いんですよ他の前なんか増資の先輩とかに置いなぁ芸者と音まんでてんな
社長からもうお前社員なんかスタッフのくせに社長とが入っていたみたいなそういうね
社内でのいじめが起きるような気がしてならないのですよ
なんでねちょっと
今度はそうもないいやそうだけど大事なこと大事なこと
社長とがでかいことなのっている
名乗ってるようじゃまだまだ僕あ
小さい男なんで新しい名前を募集しようと思いますが僕ににあいさん名前を変えて
ください
でね僕結構そういうなった名前とかっ
からで決めないんだよ
厳選して選ばせてもらうんですけどどうすか僕のこの
いろいろ
性格とかあると思うんですけどクレームというかはじめ冊を
とは違う名前を何かください
ただはじめ達郎がいい外れ冊のでも1年ぐらいやってきているっていう
岩佐なって思うんですけど
ちょっと考えてみてください僕の将来を
会社で社長冊あっていじめられている僕の姿を想像しただけで悲しくなりませんか
っというわけで
私のが募集しますねとまた朝方ないんですけどぜひね
この動画のコメント欄で名前募集しますんだよ
近いうちに
名前変えます鮭に新しい
新年度も初神殿の年度から新しい年度が始まるわけなんですけど
まあ
ゆる受け
今後もよろしくお願いしますって感じですよじゃあ